The long wait for Wonder Woman 1984 is almost
over, and you can feel the excitement of the
cast and crew.
A virtual panel discussion for the much-anticipated
sequel kicked off the DC FanDome event with
a bang on August 22, as Gal Gadot, Chris Pine,
Kristen Wiig, Pedro Pascal, and director Patty
Jenkins fielded questions from fans across
the globe, including some wonderful surprise
guests.
Jenkins and her cast reminisced fondly about
their time on set together, which must feel
almost as long ago as Diana's adventures in
World War I, after all the delays Wonder Woman
1984 has seen.
Afterward, tennis legend and Wonder Woman
superfan Venus Williams joined in to ask Gadot
and Wiig which of their characters would win
in a tennis match.
"I think Cheetah would win."
"Really?"
While this celebrity game of superhero what-if
was nothing short of delightful, an even more
special guest was waiting in the wings.
Before debuting a brand-new trailer for Wonder
Woman 1984, the FanDome panel welcomed the
original on-screen Wonder Woman herself, the
iconic former beauty queen Lynda Carter.
Despite the distance between the panel participants,
emotions ran high in the virtual Hall of Heroes
as two generations of Amazons expressed their
appreciation for each other.
Carter explained that she and Wiig have a
mutual appreciation, which they intend to
seal with a hug as soon as they can be in
the same room, and gushed with praise for
Jenkins and Gadot's take on Diana of Themyscira.
Carter became a TV icon during her three seasons
on the late '70s Wonder Woman series, and
she couldn't be happier that a whole new generation
is looking up to a whole new Diana Prince
on the big screen.
She's seen first-hand what the character means
to fans of the movies, with her own daughter
falling under the spell of Gadot's Wonder
Woman, telling her, quote, "I finally get
what Wonder Woman means to everyone."
"She said, 'Mom, I finally get it.
I finally understand why everyone idolizes
you.'"
Wonder Woman 1984 not only takes place in
a different era than the original flick did,
but it also shows a new side of the lasso-swinging
hero.
This time around, Diana has literal decades
of experience living in the world of man,
and she uses that wisdom to her benefit.
In a cover story back in June, Gadot told
Total Film,
"In Wonder Woman 1984, she's been around.
She's wiser.
She's more mature.
She's guarded.
She lost all of her friends throughout the
years.
But she's still doing the right thing.
But she is different than when we last saw
her."
In the upcoming sequel, Diana's beloved Steve
Trevor, played by Chris Pine, is back after
having presumably died a true hero's death
in the first movie.
A new face is Barbara Ann Minerva, played
by Kristen Wiig, an archeologist who works
alongside Diana and even forms a friendship
with her...only to turn into Diana's foe after
a mishap grants her the powers of a cheetah.
Then there's Pedro Pascal's Maxwell Lord,
a smarmy businessman with a villainous edge
who makes grandiose promises about granting
everyone's wishes.
In the new trailer for Wonder Woman 1984 that
also dropped during DC FanDome, fans saw Lord
giving a speech from within what appeared
to be the White House Briefing Room, and also
spotted him having a conversation with Barbara
on Air Force One.
This has led many fans to believe that Lord
perhaps wins a presidential election, using
his mysterious, wish-granting artifact to
either grant the public's wishes in exchange
for their votes or to grant his own wish for
more power.
The sequel pic features a handful of actors
in yet-undisclosed roles, including Natasha
Rothwell of Saturday Night Live and Insecure
fame, Grandfathered star Ravi Patel, and Mad
Men actor Kristoffer Polaha, so there's no
telling how many more allies or antagonists
Diana will face in this next adventure.
In all, it's looking like Wonder Woman 1984
will be a more-than-worthy follow-up flick
to the widely adored original.
Catch the film on October 2nd, 2020.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.